[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Thank You mr. president-elect
can you stand here today once and for
all and say that no one connected to you
or your campaign had any contact with
Russia leading up to or during the
presidential campaign
the essential question the world turning
question the impeachment question and
then the reporter kept talking and if
you do indeed believe that Russia was
behind the hacking what is your message
to Vladimir Putin right now and the ball
game was over trunk got to filibuster
for 321 words about how Russia would
respect America when he's leading and
Hillary's reset button and the legal
folder props and more of the poisoned
word salad constantly being spun
tableside and that addled mind of his
and he never answered the question and
his first news conference in six months
came to an end if the answer is yes even
in the slightest degree his presidency
comes to an end before it has begun
although it will linger indefinitely as
the Republicans continue to put power
ahead of country or democracy or even
independence as a nation and since Trump
chose not to say that no one connected
to him or his campaign ad as implied by
the independent dossier any contact with
Russia leading up to war during the
presidential campaign we will have to
answer it for him by circumstantial
evidence Michael Flynn Trump's incoming
national security adviser former
director of the Defense Intelligence
Agency fired in 2014 the next year he
was paid to appear at a Kremlin
sponsored TV networks gala in Moscow and
to sit a few seats from Vladimir Putin
the New York Times reports mr. Flinn
spoke to Russia's ambassador to this
country this past December 28th the day
before this country announced new
sanctions against Russia for its hacking
of the Democratic National Committee The
Washington Post says Flynn and the
Ambassador spoke several times on the
29th the international news agency
Reuters say they spoke five times there
is a law in this country against
individuals even individuals who are
soon to be part of a government
contradicting US government foreign
policy or dealing directly with enemy
nations and all we know about these
calls is the Trump gangs claim that
Flynn was setting up another
call for Trump with Vladimir Putin and
unfortunately the Trump gang has lately
been handing out lies in carload Lots in
December three veteran intelligence
professionals resigned from something
called the Cambridge intelligence
seminar at Cambridge University in
England
amid quote concerns that the seminar was
funded through an intermediary by the
Kremlin one of its past speakers was
Michael Flynn also that month Bloomberg
News reported that Flynn had partnered
with a technology company one of whose
Chiefs was quote once convicted of
trying to sell stolen biotech material
to the Russian KGB espionage Agency and
the head of Austria's far-right freedom
party founded in the 1950s by former
Nazis signed what he has described as a
cooperation agreement with Vladimir
Putin's political party and the Austrian
said that a few weeks earlier he had met
in New York with Michael Flynn and then
there's Flynn's boss separating the
United States and Germany has been any
bad policy perhaps the foremost foreign
policy of Russia since 1945 in a joint
interview at The Times of London and the
German newspaper Bild over the weekend
Trump called NATO obsolete and said the
German Chancellor Angela Merkel had made
a catastrophic mistake by letting in
quote illegals and he threatened German
automakers with huge tariffs meanwhile
Israeli media reports that the Israelis
may not share intelligence with the
Trump administration after American
intelligence said in essence to them
don't give them anything you don't want
to see end up in the hands of Iran via
the Kremlin after the revelation of the
Trump dossier last week BuzzFeed news
quoted two Israeli intelligence officers
saying that their nation and at least
one European country are separately
investigating Trump's ties to or his
compromised vulnerability to Russia but
wait you're not sure about BuzzFeed's
reporting now because they published the
full Trump dossier mistakes and false
leads included last week write a
question if that dossier had been about
Bill Clinton lurid details and all and
Donald Trump had a copy of it and Donald
Trump had read it aloud at his campaign
rallies who would have complained about
all the television networks televising
those
alleys live what news organizations
refuse to publish or broadcast Trump's
wildest accusations or the material he
read from WikiLeaks who waited until it
could prove all those allegations and
WikiLeaks were true correct none of them
did in our new world in which reporters
seek facts but let the truth fall where
it may
BuzzFeed was entirely right to publish
that dossier besides which the key to
the dossier is not the perversions in
the pee jokes it's the money to quote
the impeccable BBC reporter Paul wood
last April the CIA director was shown
intelligence that worried him it was
allegedly a tape recording of a
conversation about money from the
Kremlin going into the u.s. presidential
campaign this eventually led to the
Department of Justice to get a warrant
from the FISA Court last October they
wanted permission to intercept the
electronic records from two Russian
banks ultimately the investigation is
looking for transfers of money from
Russia to the United States each one
approved a felony offense a lawyer
outside the Department of Justice but
familiar with the case told me that
three of mr. Trump's associates were the
subject of the inquiry quote but it's
clear this is about Trump unquote he
said and Trump still defends Russia or
lumps it in with China or just ignores
the question there is a hawkish Blue Dog
Democrat seven-term former California
congresswoman and ex Undersecretary of
state named Ellen Tauscher seven years
ago she negotiated the new start arms
reduction treaty with the Russians On
January 7th she summed this all up on
Twitter quote P Otis is either
traitorously ignoring Russia hacks and
provocations or simply naive and weak
commander-in-chief to be so mr. Trump
let us ask you once again can you stand
here today once and for all and say that
no one connected to you or your campaign
had any contact with Russia leading up
to or during the presidential campaign
and if you choose again not to answer
perhaps you should begin to formulate
your answer to that question for the
impeachment trial or the trial for
espionage
resist peace